hi everybody welcome if you can take a
seat that would be great
so I'm rose I'm one of the PI data
coordinator and this is my first time
doing the intro so bear with me
so at first I want to just thank our
sponsors so numb focus for sponsoring
the meetup TD Ameritrade for sponsoring
this beautiful space and midis for
sponsoring the food so a couple of
points emergency exits so both the door
you came in and then behind here are
emergency exits if you have any feedback
there is an email address and a Twitter
at the bottom of here but you can also
talk to any of the organizers
co-organizers myself Sean and Ben who's
sitting at the back or standing at the
back excuse me
and also we're in a borrowed space
please be kind throw things away treat
it like you like it because we do like
it and we'd like to stay here so after
Katie gives her lovely talk we'll have a
Q&A at the end so please make sure that
unless it's very very quick you hold
your questions until the end please
phrase your question in the form of a
question
so no long monologues try to keep it to
30 seconds or less
avoid long statements or monologue
because I got ahead of myself and
there's time for open discussion and
conversation both of the speaker and
your other attendees after the Q&A so
now I'm going to read our PI data Code
of Conduct PI data is dedicated to
providing a harassment free meeting
space for everyone regardless of gender
sexual orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance body size race religion or
experience we do not tolerate harassment
of meeting participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate /
for professional audience including
people of many different backgrounds and
levels of experience sexual language and
imagery is not appropriate for any of
our meet-up events be kind to others do
not insult or put-down other attendees
behave professionally remember that
harassment and sec
racist or exclusionary jokes are not
appropriate for pi data attendees vital
aid violating these rules may be asked
to leave the meet up at the sole
discretion of the meetup organizers
thank you all for helping make this a
welcome welcoming friendly event for all
so we're gonna do a quick icebreaker
which was suggested by Katie our lovely
speaker and do you want to I can okay
this is a topic about which I know very
little but our icebreaker today is what
is your favorite subject
what with with the PI data code of
conduct in mind please so I'll give you
a little bit to chat among your
neighbors hi everybody let's come back
obviously a topic of much much
excitement and brought about a lot of
conversations so I hope that you learned
something new about your fellow PI data
attendees by learning about their
favorites I've read it so um this month
in data science so there's a mission I'm
sorry there's a Michigan AI symposium on
October 19th on North Campus the call
for proposals closes October 5th so you
can take a look at the website here and
our Nets
next event is um we debated how her name
was pronounced but is Tonya rudy Kovac
from devoted health on pipelines that
bend but don't break and that's gonna be
on Wednesday October 2nd also here are
there any community announcements so for
those who maybe haven't been here before
if you are looking for a job if you have
a job if generally you would have a
community announcement please
the a number chapter of the American
Statistical Association is having a
workshop practical things in computation
[Music]
great thank you so much Detroit there's
actually two machine learning data
science tracks this year great thank you
anyone else all right so now I'm gonna
introduce Katie
so Katie Bauer was a founding member of
reddit's data science team and currently
manages its consumer data science and
analytics team she has previously worked
in search digital advertising and online
retail and is known for using company
hackathons as an excuse to bake cakes at
work so take it away Katie thank you for
having me and arbors lovely I have only
been here for a little bit less than 24
hours but I've already consumed an
irresponsible number of brownies from
Zingerman's so I think I'm not so good
start
I'm going to talk to you all about
building a time on-site metric at reddit
that's one of the first things I did and
when I started working there and yeah it
should be a fun time so to give you a
little bit of information about myself
as this is basically the stuff from the
bio but with a picture of me as a snoo
next to it I have worked previously on
natural language search search engine
for things to do ad tech retail I've
been kind of all over the data space and
I was one of the first data science
hires that read it I've seen our data
stack transformed tremendously in that
time we were working in hive when I
first started there which
slow and painful now we're entirely in
the Google cloud ecosystem which is
awesome and we're talking a little bit
about that today
I currently manage a team called the
consumer data team which is data science
and analytics concerns related to
probably the parts of Reddit that you
see unless you happen to be a digital
advertiser that's what the the rest of
the data science team does at reddit and
I bake a lot of cakes I've even won
awards for baking cakes in the office
this is an actual belt that is sitting
on my desk when you press the champions
button it like makes firework sounds
it's it's pretty awesome it's just a pie
I've also baked pies and bread and lots
of stuff I bake a lot of things so how
many of you have used read it before
okay that's good
hopefully the favorite subreddit
question wasn't too awkward for those of
you who have not used read it reddit is
some people consider it like a social
network I think of it sort of as an anti
social network because it's not about
talking to people you know it's about
talking to strangers about things you
care about it's it's a lot more like a
forum people mostly come for topical
based communities where you can even
talk about literally any interests
there's a lot of gaming stuff but
there's also makeup there's also like
support communities for people who have
diseases that are quite rare that you'll
never meet someone in real life with
them and people will have really
meaningful validating conversations
these communities end up having lots of
interactions with each other some
communities like to send from other
communities some of them have positive
relationships and they all kind of blend
together in a way that's weird and
wonderful there's also a ton of cat
pictures on reddit so if you like that
probably a good place to go so before we
begin I'm going to establish a few
foundational concepts that are important
for understanding the talk ahead those
are sessions event logs and something
called screen views which is a concept
internal to read it but pretty intuitive
we'll start with sessions sessions are a
industry-wide concept it's a pretty
standard thing you can think of them as
being like a container for all of the
actions
so that you have on a site when you
visit it and the way it works is
anything you do ends up being in that
container until there's 30 minutes of
inactivity then you're such an expires
and you have a new session the next time
you come back so to give sort of a
concrete representation of that if you
come to Reddit or any site really at
2:01 your session would expire at 2:31
then if you do another action at 202
then 232 would be the time it expires
and that keeps refreshing until you stop
doing stuff that boundary sounds
probably pretty arbitrary
for example if say you go to an
e-commerce site and you go to the splash
page you see a bunch of shirts you see
one you like you click on that but then
you get a phone call you get up and you
leave your desk and you're gone for
thirty minutes you come back at exactly
31 minutes and you're on that page of
that shirt that you wanted to buy you
add it to cart and that is a new session
so that artificially creates two
sessions that's messy you could have the
total opposite where you get done with
that phone call early you come back
exactly in 29 minutes and you don't get
a new session this is this is a super
fuzzy thing but this is an industry
strand standard definition of a session
and even if it is a little weird the
reason that it's standard is because
it's like having a different definition
of centimeters or something if you went
to a different city it'd be weird we all
want to know that we're talking about
the same thing so we've all kind of
agreed to define sessions this way the
next thing is event logs the name is
pretty intuitive that's like kind of
like a Captain's Log or something
it's everything that happens written
down time stamped this is the foundation
of pretty much all commercial data
science and machine learning at least on
the consumer web and this is an example
of some events in our data warehouse
this was just like a select star for the
30th of August to generate this
screenshot and of note on here there's
basically a naming framework which is
this thing called source
that's not super important it's just a
way of identifying events and then
there's two different time stamps an end
point time stamp and a client time stamp
that will be important later and then
some other stuff there's tons of stuff
on these different events but what's
important is everything you do on a
website or most of the things you do are
usually tracked in this way the Met logs
are really important as I said they're
the foundation of a lot of the
commercial Internet if your house is
burning down save the event logs forget
the machine learning you can create a
new a new machine learning system you
can recreate your blockchain but the
event logs are super important because
they're the foundation of everything and
they have to be good garbage in garbage
out and finally screen views like I said
pretty intuitive concept it is just a
page is loaded on Reddit and displayed
in your browser or your app or whatever
you're using to access the site this is
a subreddit that I enjoy I wouldn't say
it's my favorite but it's called sue
Bobby it's mangled corporate logos
spelled wrong it's pretty goofy but if I
happen to open sue bubby I fire a event
source action known as global view
screen that is a screen view this is one
of the most common events that happens
on reddit because most people are
lurkers who don't comment or post or
vote or anything they just load pages
they look at stuff they read they leave
and the fact that screen views are so
common that every single user has them
regardless of whether they have an
account or not that is why we used it as
the basis of time on site and now we're
going to get to the good stuff yes
look you can specifically event like an
outbound link but like we so like oh I
can get into this a little bit but
essentially like we can control tracking
for things that happen on our site but
once someone leaves our site we don't
really know what's happening all right
so to build time on site there were
three important ingredients one of which
was Google bigquery which is a data Lake
and is pretty much all just writing
sequel it's a great analytics tool it's
honestly the tool that I use more than
anything else in my work as a data
scientist at reddit the next is Apache
airflow which is an ETL framework ETL
for those of you who don't know is
extract transform load which sounds like
a very old term and it is but you hear
people talk about a lot in industry it's
something that takes those raw event
logs and converts them into something
that is business logic I've done a ton
of data warehousing and ETL work as a
data scientist I've read it and the
final ingredient in building time
on-site was a lot of frustration well
we'll get to that so let's start with
the bigquery piece bigquery like I said
all sequel and actually the methodology
for calculating time on site was pretty
simple it did involve an advanced sequel
function which is called a window
function window functions are actually a
big family of functions and they're
they're a lot like an aggregate function
where you know you have like a column
you're grouping by and then getting like
an average of a number or the maximum or
the minimum or the count or something
like that window functions kind of allow
you to do that in place by picking
something and partitioning over it and
creating a window so to speak so to give
you an idea of what that looks like
these are some window functions and
actually this is time on site it seems
pretty simple right so here in time on
site we have a little better than me
pointing so we are taking an aggregate
function here we're getting the max
timestamp and we're partitioning by a
unique
combination of a user ID the app they
are accessing write it through and their
session ID that's it you're just getting
the max in the minimum timestamp
associated with both of those things and
then here you are taking the difference
of timestamps and getting that in
seconds and that is a session length
window functions are really nice because
this ends up being a very clean query
there are a lot of different performance
characteristics of Siebel that become
important when you're crunching a ton of
data and joining things which you might
have to do if you were using aggregate
functions to achieve this this makes it
way simpler this makes it way easier to
understand and this is very helpful and
readable code what's notable about this
query in particular is we are looking at
an event called global view screen and
then this other event that is also used
in time on site although it was not
originally part of our time on site
definition called post consume Coast I
also want to point out that there are
two different session links here and
I'll explain why in a bit but first
let's talk about air flow air flow is a
scheduler basically it runs a bunch of
sequel queries for you and it schedules
them with a cron job but it is very
fancy you can configure it to have
dependencies make sure that like one one
task is run another task will only start
running once that one is finished it
allows you to do stuff at custom times
of day it allows you to like make sure
that it's always checking if something
has completed on a previous day you can
get pretty fancy with it but I didn't
really get too fancy with this in time
on site it was basically just run this
every day and what is interesting about
air flow is that it creates these
elaborate graphs called directed async a
cyclic graphs otherwise known as DAGs
and usually they're pretty
straightforward pretty simple it's like
just a line this is one of the more
interesting looking gags that we have it
read it
this is calculating a bunch of important
business metrics and what's important
about this first of all you can see the
dependency chains where this is just
like a check to make sure Robins are
populated in the database then we run
all these different aggregate tables run
another one hit
check that check feeds into this thing
more aggregates are calculated etc etc
and sleep on that reached the end but if
this never reaches the end because
something upstream fails the entire
thing crashes this was a problem at
various points but again we'll get to
that for the most part pretty
straightforward pretty simple I wrote a
sequel query I schedule it in airflow
and voila I had time on site but it was
not that easy and that is because of
distributed systems the modern web is a
bunch of servers in a cloud somewhere
that communicate with your actual device
whether it's your laptop your cell phone
your PC and for the most part this
communication goes off without a hitch
they pass information without any
problems but sometimes they just kind of
fall over and they don't this is where
the frustration comes in once I had
built this time on site aggregate I
needed to do some QA I needed to make
sure that things look to the way they
were supposed to look so I started off
by just looking at the lengths of
sessions did they seem like sane amounts
of time that people would spend on
Reddit and there were some pretty long
sessions but I mean I personally can get
lost in the comments section of a really
good write-up post so it wasn't that bad
except there were really really long
sessions and not you know there could
plausibly be long sessions where you
have like sort of a slow burn of someone
being in class or at work where they are
constantly hitting that like 29 minute
mark where the session doesn't quite
expire even though they weren't active
for that whole period that the sentient
session length actually ends up
happening because you're just getting
the minimum and maximum timestamp
associated with a session ID but they're
also surprisingly frequent and there
were sessions that were actually like
full 24-hour periods and I realized at
that point that something was definitely
wrong with my aggregate there was
something about the data that was not
clean so I brought myself back into
distributed systems world to try and
understand what was happening and if
you'll recall there was two timestamps
on the event logs
you have this end point time stamp and
client time stamp these are time stamps
associated with something that happens
on like your device like your laptop or
your phone and the end point time stamp
is what happens on the server in general
there's conventional wisdom and industry
that if you have a version of data that
is generated by a client versus a server
you trust the server because the server
is like one single point where
everything is consistent whereas things
might be implemented differently on the
the desktop site versus the native
mobile app people also do particularly
crazy things on their phone for example
if you are playing candy crush and you
need to get more lives you can just
change the day on your phone because
they regenerate based on time so people
often have very bad time stamps on their
phones and it's not really trustworthy
so I had built time on site using a
server-side timestamp but that was a
problem
normally time stamps but the difference
between a client timestamp and a
server-side timestamp is like
milliseconds it's not a big deal but for
some of these they're actually hours
apart the the phone or the desktop app
or whatever client was actually
accessing ready was logging this
timestamp way before the server was
lines three and four actually have
events happening on separate days and
this was really bizarre I dug into it a
little bit more and I figured out some
patterns one of which was four sessions
that had this problem of very long
lengths there would be weird bursts of
events firing all at the same time where
the the server would has just suddenly
have like ten events all in rapid
succession and you would also have that
happening only on native mobile apps so
iOS and Android and this was really
bizarre and I went over to talk to an
iOS engineer and it was because of
distributed systems it turns out they
make it really hard to figure out what
time something happened
and another particularly big problem
with native mobile apps in particular
I'm saying the word particular a lot I'm
sorry everyone the the problem that you
experience a lot is sending events as
you are tracking behavior and an app
requires a lot of battery so in the past
an ios engineer seeing the performance
characteristics of constantly sending
events was turning the phone into a bit
of a hand warmer
it was just destroying people's battery
life so they had implemented a system
that bashed up events and would send
them all at once so they would be logged
with a correct timestamp or at least
correct according to the device on the
client-side timestamp but the server
would not get them until that batch was
sent and if someone closes their app
before that batch was sent we just don't
know about it until days later or hours
later or whenever they open their app
again so we spent some time
investigating the difference between a
client-side time on site versus a
server-side time on site and we found
out that the actual relative distance
between events on the client was more
reliable for calculating time on site
even if the absolute time was wrong so
you would get your actual day that the
session happened from the server-side
timestamp and the distance between the
events was the client-side timestamp I
felt pretty good about this I thought I
was nearing the completion of the time
on site project but I knew I had to do
more QA yes they were pretty small for
the most part like we didn't have that
many of it so it was like a margin of
error that we found was acceptable so as
I dug into more QA I still found some
egregiously long sessions and I wasn't
sure what to do about this so I started
to get really granular for these really
long sessions I started looking at the
relative timestamps and just every
single event I actually leaned on
another window function which is called
lead that allows you to create a
partition over whatever unit you want in
this case it was a session ID
and then order actually hang on haha its
circle on this slide a session ID so
just making a window over a session ID
and then ordering everything by a client
timestamp so I can see things happening
in order and with the leave function you
can actually create in one row a
timestamp of an event and then the event
that happened immediately after it which
allowed you to calculate the difference
in time between those two events so I
was able to check are there we are we
actually firing events where they should
have been assigned a new session was
there a 30 minute period of inactivity
between these events that should have
generated a new session ID and it turned
out that was true there was thing that
was or one thing that was not like the
others
and that was all of these session IDs
being assigned to events that really
should have been at the start of a new
session our good old friend distributive
systems was responsible for this so the
reason that this was happening was that
when someone hadn't been using their app
for a while and they should have
received a new session ID they were
getting an old session ID so an old
session ID which was associated with
events that were happening hours before
was getting appended to the start a
rather hang on I'm gonna say this
backwards these events that were really
part of a new session we're being
appended to an old session because the
old session ID was being recycled this
is what's known as a race condition or a
race hazard which sounds way more
exciting but it's a common problem you
experience in native mobile development
which is where you need things to happen
in the correct order but there's
something that you can't control that
makes it so they won't happen in the
correct order and in this case that
thing that you can't control is a Wi-Fi
connection our session IDs are actually
tracked on a server and they are
assigned by a server so if you open up
your phone and you get into reddit on
Android or iOS you will potentially not
have a Wi-Fi connection or your phone
hasn't connected yet but you'll be
loading a page you'll be viewing a page
and you'll get a screen view event and
because a session ID was not yet
available you would get an old session
ID
and that was causing sessions to be
extraneously long I ended up creating a
very hairy sub dag within our time
on-site calculation to deal with this
and the reason for this was that we had
a board meeting coming up and we needed
to be able to report accurate
information on time on site so I started
to do something that was a little insane
for the first version of this for our
browser-based access points for reddit
which is like that just like the regular
desktop site the like em web version
when you open up your phone in a browser
the version you get there and then
something called amp which is like a
Google specific technology that's not
really important to this talk but it's
like a cached version of the site that
Google serves you if you open up the
site from a Google search those were all
pretty accurate and we didn't have this
problem but the native mobile apps
Android and iOS
we did have this problem a lot so the
first thing I did was I would order
every single Android and iOS session and
put that into an aggregate table and
then I would take every single event
used to calculate time on site and put
that in order in an aggregate table and
then I would use the lead function to
get the difference between all of these
different events and see if any of them
actually should have been assigned a new
session if they were I then created a
table where I corrected all of the
events session IDs and then I would
calculate time on site that was not
worth doing you never do anything like
this because this is so hard to
understand if you did not write it and
even if you did write it it's hard to
understand and debug this is TechEd it
don't write tech debt if you can help it
fortunately I had talked to the iOS and
Android engineers and they told me that
they had come up with a great fix to
help deal with this problem of orphaned
events being given the wrong session ID
and that was something called inactive
session zero zero zero when a session ID
was not available because the phone
could not contact the server they would
just give it this session ID and at the
time I was so tired of working on time
on site that
I was cool with that and it worked
pretty well until it didn't there was
one evening where I was actually
preparing to go to a happy hour I was
smelling my teammates and I got an alert
from Pedro Duty telling me that all of
our important business reporting ETLs
failed and as I mentioned earlier
because they were all in the same dag
and air flow everything was unavailable
we were about to enter some quarterly
planning so I had an exec who was very
angry at me and I had to fix this so
instead of going to my happy hour I sat
down in the lobby of the building and
just started rapidly trying to debug my
messy ETL and figure out where it was
going wrong after a couple of hours and
a lot of self-doubt we found ourselves
looking at one of these queries that was
using the lead function window functions
coming back to bite us in particular our
problem was coming from the partitioning
by sessionid frustration as I mentioned
session IDs normally they're recycled
pretty regularly and the average session
on reddit has about 17 screen views in
active session zero zero zero had
980,000 screen views in a single day
so having to partition over a session ID
that had this many events and put
everything in order was killing airflow
sorting things is one of the most memory
intensive things you can do in sequel
performance characteristics do matter in
sequel if you're crunching enough data
so fortunately after figuring that out
we were able to implement effects pretty
fast where we just manually filtered out
inactive session zero zero zero
I'm not happy with that solution in part
because it's an obstacle that you have
to know it exists
to avoid it anytime a solution requires
reading documentation or tribal
knowledge or that sort of thing
someone's going to stub their toe I stub
my toe somewhat regularly against
inactive session zero zero zero for a
variety of reasons if I don't remember
to actively filter it out in a query I
also it's a problem because it
establishes a pattern that is then
replicated in other cases the current
time on site query actually has a manual
filtering of places where people used
user IDs in exactly the same way so we
had user IDs like anonymous we had user
IDs like access to chat without login
and a problem with native mobile
development in particular is that old
versions of the app will be in the wild
for a very long time so if there is a
bug in the data logging for that app
version you're gonna be dealing with it
for the next two years but despite my
complaints Taman so it's actually in a
pretty good state we have not had an ETL
failure for time on site in particular
in about two years which is pretty
unusual so where is time on site today
first of all it's really important for
us in terms of understanding user
journeys and how users learn about the
site and get into the site in particular
we had a really good analysis by one of
our data scientists where they found out
that if a new user finds a subreddit and
spends ten minutes on it they've found a
home on the site they found the
community that resonates with them and
they'll come back and that has informed
strategy it's made it very important to
increase discoverability of subreddits
and now we're using time on site to
train machine learning algorithms for
that purpose a lot of popular ranking is
actually trained by time on site a lot
of other excuse me discovery mechanisms
like push notifications or training
recommendation units email digests all
that it's powered by time on site and
remarkably we're using almost exactly
the same definition as the original one
that we created two years ago there have
in situations where people have thought
like oh maybe we should track this like
more more hard-coded we should do it on
the server there was actually a whole
situation where we implemented a new
event that was called the heartbeat
event that would fire every single time
that brought live fire at every 30
seconds that someone had the app open or
the browser open a problem with this was
that every single tab would fire an
event and people browse Reddit with lots
of tabs open and if data volume
destroyed airflow before we essentially
ddosed ourselves with that one
but that's perhaps to talk for another
time but yeah time on site is something
that has taught me the value of doing
something simple and robust and building
complexity from that starting place and
if there's anything you should take away
simple is good you can get pretty far
with simple thank you and now I can take
questions
yes the hot sort is actually like it's
an older vote counting thing best is a
bunch of different ensembles of machine
learning algorithms it depends on what
you like best is more personalized
popular is more of like okay that's good
I mean best is also only gonna give you
your subscriptions popular it's gonna be
anything yes how are we dealing with
bots and web scrapers yeah is that a
good summary I mean I we don't really
have any ability to track at least on
desktop if someone's taking a screenshot
sure sure we I mean we do have bought
detection for that sort of thing we
filter them out of like experiment
reporting but for the most part it's
pretty benign we also have like a like a
registered way of interacting with one
of our api's which is I don't remember
what the acronym stands for but it's
called pro like we have a pretty robust
third-party developer ecosystem who used
that and at least in that case we know
explicitly that it is like some kind of
automated service accessing it no for
the most part it's just like a bash
nightly job a lot of people think they
need real-time analytics but there's
very few things that you need to know so
urgently that you need to have it in
real time that's like more for like if
you want to do like air flow is not even
really a good technology for that you'd
probably want to do something like blink
if you wanted to do like a real-time
calculation
you mean for first Greenview events mmm
the calculation is very fast in bigquery
it's like less than a minute to do it
for every user for an entire day the
more days you look back the more
difficult it gets in the more it's
likely to fall down but it runs pretty
fast
it's like written into an aggregate
table so like if you want to know like
what was the time on site for this user
for this subreddit for the last 60 days
you can look at that in an aggregate
table that's actually how some of our
push notifications work so the fast run
runs in a minute Wow he wanted to
clarify that
like running this calculation for every
user in a day that it took one minute
yeah Vic where is really nice I like it
a lot yeah the 907 1000
session zero zero zeros that you were
essentially filter out is that how how
material is that relative to the volume
of all the data that's really small yeah
we received some hundred billion events
every day yeah I mean it's not looking
at every single event actually looking
at the screen Beus yes in the back
sometimes when we're like you giving an
estimate for an important purpose or
like a huge aggregate will filter out
things that are particularly long like
maybe sessions that are over two hours
or something but for the most part it's
it's not too bad yes yeah they're
actually pretty hard to track like even
people who do have an account like I'm
probably like for da you everyday
between like having like a main account
like an alt account like getting on my
phone where I'm not logged in there's a
lot of different ways that we we can't
accurately track like how many people
are like one specific user and for the
most part that's a good thing like we
don't really want to invade our users
privacy's by like blinking all their
alts together or anything like that yes
sure well I was looking by app where all
these long sessions were occurring so
like was it on desktop like I was just
trying to like validate it against other
external things that could maybe
validate an intuition that I had and I
noticed that like most of them were ios
and android happening so i figured i
would go talk to the engineer to see if
there's a problem with the data itself
yeah I mean I explained what I was
trying to do I explain the situation and
since I was talking about how session
IDs were assigned they were able to find
like the specific place where that was
implemented and that made the
conversation fairly straightforward they
still have to do some digging but the
fact that I could speak generally to the
type of problem I was solving made it
easier to search through the codebase
and find what might be causing it it
really depends if it's something that's
like I mean I guess need a mobile
development particular there's App Store
releases so like if you don't get
something in like within that normal
release cycle like you can't hop fix it
in but for the most part like it's not
going to go out until like maybe two
weeks later or something but if it's
like a really important business
critical thing they're gonna patch that
in it's a little easier with like web
development because you can release it
any time for that but
but you're thinking about like Team
Dynamics you said you were one of the
first hires there can you talk about
maybe the process over time like when
you go to the other teams are they
responsible to your names
besides Tim gonna take a little while
for you to get there or are you just
like acting in
you know her reacting to whatever
yeah that has changed over time it's
evolved and like a lot of companies have
different philosophies about where the
data science org should live within
their company at least when I first
started at reddit we had sort of an
embedded model where like data
scientists worked with particular
product groups and I was working with a
group that had embedded iOS and Android
engineers who I can talk to you pretty
pretty easily
and I was also particularly working on
time on site because it was a machine
learning focused team and they wanted to
optimize for it so that made that
relationship pretty natural if you don't
have a relationship with that team like
you weren't embedded or you've never
worked with them before like that's
usually something you have to cultivate
a little bit more but something I've
found to be extremely valuable as a data
scientist is just acknowledging that
communication is a huge part of your
work like usually like if you can
explain what you're doing to someone
they're like okay that makes sense and
they're they're happy to help you out
but if you just like dump a spreadsheet
or like a you like throw a bunch of
statistics at them and don't explain
they're like cool I don't have time for
this so it's about just like treating
people with respect and making sure - I
don't know come at it in a constructive
way
the the data science team doesn't really
I mean like they're like every company
is going to have like different types of
data like their I mean they you can have
like Salesforce data you could have like
HR data but the data science team is
mostly concerned with our consumer or
most of the data science team is mostly
concerned with things that happen with a
consumer product we're not really
looping in third-party data at all
back on on culture if you find there's a
kind of a split between
the more academic data scientists the
behavioral economists and the applied
math huge these and and and and
essentially the team that gets the data
ready for whatever model they want to
try and build yeah so to repeat that
question is there like a divide between
academic data scientists who are mostly
concerned with modeling versus people
who would prepare data for modeling
stead of good summary that is going to
vary a lot depending on what kind of
company you're at some companies like
that's all data scientists do that some
companies data scientists are a part of
like the full stack process of like
preparing data and then also modeling it
it really depends on what a company
needs and where a company isn't it's
it's stage of life I definitely am more
of the bent of like prepare data that's
most of the work of a data scientist and
then model understand the problem then
apply a model probably a simple one if
you understand the problem well but
bigger companies have a lot more space
for people who are doing like pure
academic research type work but a lot of
smaller companies at least in the Bay
Area tech scene they're people who are
trying to solve problems with data
ah this happened mostly of course like
the original like main thing was like a
month and then it was like a month later
that we had that very critical failure
that I missed a happy hour for and that
was like a couple hours of work just
debugging and figuring that out I know
that for myself not only to thank you
were great to talk about that I will
make sure that at 29 minutes in I'll
make sure to close my tabs and my brows
thank you
[Applause]
you